I don't think that our culture is
misogynist misogynists exist but that's
not typical are you familiar with the
women a wonderful bias yes both men and
women are more positively predisposed to
news stories that complement women's
outcomes or say that a woman achieved
something than say that a man achieved
something which doesn't fit at all with
the idea that we live in a misogynous
culture I don't think that we hate women
I think though the way that women are
sort of regarded is as like your mom you
love your mom you don't want Obe her
necessarily you don't necessarily
respect her the puzzle basically as to
why Wom are so consistently regarded in
a particular Way Cross culturally as
being like lovable but also a bit like
lower status is that women are
considered to be kind of adjacent to
children so in the same way that we love
children but we're not going to let them
vote what the human brain does is
there's men there's women there's
children so women are in a kind of
intermediary position